Sure, it's easy to understand why someone
would regret shooting a superhero flick
rife with cheesy lines and marketing plugs. But
despising your part in one of the most beloved
blockbusters of the '90s? You won't believe
some of the movies these actors regret filming.
He may be one of Hollywood's biggest action
heroes, but Sylvester Stallone has had his
failures too. From the much-maligned "Judge
Dredd" to the awkward '80s Dolly Parton drama
"Rhinestone," he probably regrets a great many
films in his career. But there's one '90s flop
that stands head and shoulders above the rest: The
1992 action-comedy "Stop! Or My Mom Will Shoot."
"Stop! Or My Mom Will Shoot" is best
known for being the film Stallone was
tricked into making by none other than
action rival Arnold Schwarzenegger,
who pretended to be after the role
himself. He told The Hollywood Reporter,
"I had heard Schwarzenegger was
going to do that movie and I said,
'I'm going to beat him to
it.' I think he set me up."
Instantly regretting it, he was confused
by the rest of the film's casting,
particularly "Golden Girls"
star Estelle Getty. He recalled,
"[It] was supposed to be like 'Throw
Momma From the Train' with the mom as
this really nasty piece of work. Instead,
you hire the nicest woman in Hollywood,
Estelle Getty, who you wish was your mother."
In the years since, Stallone has made his
hatred of the film known, telling GQ in 2017,
"If you ever want someone to confess to murder,
just make him or her sit through that film.
They will confess to anything after 15 minutes!"
The moment you hear the name "George Clooney" on
a list of regrettable movies, you probably already
know which movie is being lamented. It's one of
the most infamous comic book adaptations ever,
a film so bad it killed a franchise and nearly
destroyed multiple careers. Released in 1997 and
directed by Joel Schumacher, "Batman & Robin" was
the fourth film in the series and Clooney's first
big blockbuster project after starring in the
hit medical drama "ER." Needless to say, it was
also a notorious flop for a variety of reasons
– including a shameless American Express plug.
"Never leave the cave without it."
Instead of making Clooney
a sought-after action hero,
he had to spend years apologizing for
it. Clooney said in an appearance on
the Graham Norton Show in 2015 that he always
apologizes for his involvement in the film.
"But, you know, I thought at the time it was
going to be a very good career move. It wasn't."
And he hasn't stopped trashing the film.
In 2020, in an interview with Howard Stern,
he went further into just how awful
the flick really is. The star remarked,
"Akiva Goldsman — who's won the Oscar for
writing since then — he wrote the screenplay,
and it's a terrible screenplay,
he'll tell you […] Joel Schumacher,
who just passed away, directed it,
and he'd say, 'Yeah, it didn't work.'"
But Clooney didn't just lay the
blame at the feet of others;
he readily admits to his own failure
playing Bruce Wayne. He conceded,
"The truth of the matter is, I was bad
in it […] We all whiffed on that one."
Star of countless big screen classics, Tom Hanks
counts six Academy Award nominations to his name,
including two wins. He also has seven
Primetime Emmy Awards as a producer,
on such favorites as "Band of Brothers" and
"Olive Kitteridge." Yet even with all his success,
Hanks still has a movie that he finds
hard to stomach years later. Directed
by Brian De Palma and co-starring
Bruce Willis, Melanie Griffith,
and Morgan Freeman, "The Bonfire of the
Vanities" makes Hanks cringe to this day.
A black comedy based on the celebrated 1987
novel by Tom Wolfe, the film sees Hanks play
Sherman McCoy, a Wall Street power player,
husband, and father whose wealth isn't quite
what it seems. As his finances get stretched to
their limits, he accidentally kills a bystander
with his car while out with his mistress.
When this is discovered by a local attorney,
it leads to a firestorm. It's a story with
a lot to say on racism, class inequality,
and the excess of the '80s, but even
with all of its high-minded themes,
it just isn't very good. He told Oprah
Winfrey in a 2001 interview in O,
"It's one of the crappiest movies ever made."
And Hanks wasn't alone in this opinion:
The film was a box office bomb that
was met with derision from critics,
making many "worst of the '90s" lists.
Getting his start on TV in "The Fresh Prince of
Bel-Air," Will Smith shot to big screen stardom
in the '90s with a string of blockbuster hits. He
had a four-year run of success that's hard to top,
with "Bad Boys" in 1995, "Independence
Day" in 1996, "Men in Black" in 1997,
and the criminally underrated political thriller
"Enemy of the State" in 1998. Unfortunately,
his luck just couldn't hold, and in
1999, he made perhaps the worst film
of his career. He's said many times he wishes
he'd never made it. He told People in 2021,
"'Wild Wild West' is a thorn in my side. To
see myself in chaps ... I don't like it."
Why did he do the movie at all? Smith says
it was his own fault for getting carried
away by that incredible run of blockbusters.
Smith said in an interview with GQ in 2016,
"I had so much success that I
started to taste global blood,
and my focus shifted from my artistry to
winning [...] I found myself promoting
something because I wanted to win, versus
promoting something because I believed in it."
To make matters worse, "Wild Wild West" is the
movie Smith made after turning down the role
of Neo in "The Matrix," a game-changingly
bad decision he still laments to this day.
By 1995, Whoopi Goldberg had already long
established herself as one of the most
talented actresses in Hollywood. She received an
Academy Award nomination in 1986 for her leading
role in "The Color Purple" and took home
the trophy for best supporting actress in
1991 for "Ghost." She'd featured in a recurring
role on the acclaimed sci-fi series "Star Trek:
The Next Generation," appeared in a pair of
"Sister Act" movies, and was coming off her
role as Shenzi in "The Lion King." That's
when she made easily the worst movie in her
career — and she knew she would regret it
the moment she stepped before the camera.
"He's a cop, we gotta make
him look like a real cop."
"I'm too sexy for my clothes."
That's because Goldberg's part in "Theodore
Rex" wasn't actually one that she wanted to
perform. She'd even gone so far as to try
to back out of the project, but was forced
to follow through. She's never been shy about
expressing her disdain for the movie since,
either. During her days as a co-host on the
daytime talk show "The View," she once said,
"[The film] makes no sense to anyone."
Despite the fact that it has its fans, she
wishes it could be erased from existence.
When it comes to superhero movies, there may be
no role more coveted than Batman — but it wasn't
always that way. Played by Adam West in the 1966
television series and an accompanying theatrical
release, it wasn't until Michael Keaton put
on the cape and cowl for Tim Burton's 1989
"Batman" that all of Hollywood took notice. So,
when Keaton stepped away after a pair of films,
the role became a sought-after one. Val
Kilmer was as excited as you would imagine
to get behind the wheel of the Batmobile for
1995's "Batman Forever." But years before
Clooney regretted its sequel, Kilmer ended up
having a miserable experience playing Batman.
Unfortunately, along with Keaton, director Tim
Burton exited the threequel. Incoming helmer
Joel Schumacher brought with him a very
different take on the character. That's
when Kilmer's enthusiasm faded.
He said in his 2021 documentary
"Whatever boyhood excitement I had was crushed
by the reality of the Batsuit. Yes, every boy
wants to be Batman. They actually want to be
him ... not necessarily play him in a movie."
But that's what Kilmer was doing, and
the critical drubbing the movie received
further killed his interest in continuing
to play the character. Two years later,
Kilmer quit the series, unwilling to
debase himself further with another sequel.
It's hard to imagine an actor regretting
not just the biggest role in their career,
but a film that currently sits among the
highest-grossing ever made. Now imagine
that film is also one of the most beloved films
in the history of cinema, with fans of all ages
passionate about its action, adventure, and
romance. What could there be to regret? Well,
there's no need to imagine, because the movie
is James Cameron's "Titanic," and its star Kate
Winslet who isn't so thrilled that people
are still rewatching it year after year.
Not because the movie is bad, but because
she can't stand her own performance in it.
"Stay back! Don't come any closer!"
Winslet said during press interviews
for the film's 3D re-release in 2012,
"It's awful [...] It sounds terribly
self-indulgent but actors do tend to
be very self-critical. I have a hard
time watching any of my performances,
but watching 'Titanic' I was just like,
'Oh God, I want to do that again.'"
It's a performance — and film —
that she can barely sit through,
despite its lofty reputation and
millions of adoring fans. She mentioned,
"Every single scene, I'm like 'Really,
really? You did it like that? Oh my God.'"
Still, she has some consolation: Winslet was
nominated for an Academy Award for her role as
Rose, though she might be glad she lost out to
Helen Hunt to avoid further attention for it.
Sandra Bullock became one of Hollywood's
biggest rising starlets after appearing
opposite Sylvester Stallone in the 1993
action movie "Demolition Man." A year later
she starred with Keanu Reeves in the blockbuster
classic "Speed." But when a sequel was greenlit,
Reeves chose not to return. This gave Bullock
the rare chance to take a leading role in
her very own action movie, with Jason
Patric as her co-star. Unfortunately,
when all was said and done, the movie was a
huge flop, barely making back its own budget.
And in the years since, the actress has admitted
just how much she wishes it had never happened.
In 2022 she was asked by TooFab if there was
any movie in her career that she initially
didn't like, but that perhaps she'd learned to
appreciate because of its fan following. She said,
"I have one no one came around to and I'm still
embarrassed I was in. It's called 'Speed 2.'"
Admitting that the plot of a slow-moving boat
never really made a lick of sense to begin with,
Bullock revealed that the entire
project was a shameful cinema sin
from top to bottom. After the interviewer
claimed they enjoyed the film, she said,
"That's one I wished I hadn't done and no fans
came around, that I know of, except for you."
Bruce Willis made a name for himself on the
small screen as Detective David Addison in
"Moonlighting" before making the
leap to the movies. When he did,
he became an instant star thanks to
1988's "Die Hard," where he played
grizzled cop John McClane. He struggled
to recapture that film's success, though,
in disappointments like "Hudson Hawk" and
"Billy Bathgate." Perhaps trying to go back
to the kind of role that made him a movie star,
he became a cop in 1993's "Striking Distance."
Willis plays a homicide detective named Tom Hardy,
but it isn't quite the same role as John McClane.
For one thing, Hardy is relegated to the role
of River Rescue Squad, far from the city-based
excitement of "Die Hard." The movie wasn't a hit,
and was mercilessly maligned by critics. When
looking back on his career in a chat with Ain't
it Cool News, Willis threw the film under the bus,
calling it a dog for which he hangs his
head in shame. Thankfully, it's a movie
that most audiences have seemed to forget about,
being happier to focus on his winning entries.
The 1994 romantic comedy "I Love
Trouble" had everything going for it,
starting with its star-studded cast.
Led by Julia Roberts and Nick Nolte,
it boasted a pair of big names who
producers dreamed would become a classic
Hollywood couple, ala Hepburn and Tracy.
Unfortunately, the result was a total dud,
with the two leads having fewer sparks than
a dead Zippo lighter. It completely bombed
at the box office. But that's not the only
reason why Julia Roberts regrets the film.
Famously, Roberts and Nolte did not
get along at all on the set of the
film. According to contemporary accounts in The
Los Angeles Times, the two feuded constantly,
with Roberts more than a little annoyed
by his male chauvinism. The fact that he
reportedly openly insulted her on set didn't
help. Rumors flew that things got so bad that
they refused to even be near each other,
often filming their scenes separately with
stand-ins. Though these details were
never commented on by either of them,
Roberts did openly call her co-star "completely
disgusting" in that Los Angeles Times interview,
and Nolte has since responded with equal contempt
for her. Suffice it to say, the production was
an extremely unpleasant one that Roberts
doesn't even like to talk about these days.
In 1988, Bob Hoskins starred in one of the first
— and still best — movies to combine live-action
and animation when he played Eddie Valiant in
"Who Framed Roger Rabbit?" But five years later,
he tried to duplicate that success in another
family film ... and wound up leading a movie
so famously awful it single-handedly
destroyed an entire genre. Later in life,
Hoskins wasn't shy about discussing just how much
he regretted ever starring in the 1993 video game
adaptation of "Super Mario Bros." He said in a
wide-ranging interview with The Guardian in 2007,
"The worst thing I ever did?
Super Mario Brothers. It was
a f—--g nightmare. The whole
experience was a nightmare."
**screaming**
He continued his expletive-laden rant
against the film, going on to say,
"It had a husband-and-wife team directing, whose
arrogance had been mistaken for talent. After so
many weeks their own agent told them to get
off the set! F—--g* nightmare. F—--g idiots."
Ultimately, the film wound up as poorly
received by audiences and critics as it
was by Hoskins. It gave the emerging genre
of video game adaptations a bad name,
and pretty much everyone involved
probably wishes it never happened.
"I used to play King Lear."
Since she rose to fame in the late '70s as Laurie
Strode in John Carpenter's "Halloween," Jamie Lee
Curtis has made scores of iconic films.
But she's made almost as many bad ones,
too. In fact, Curtis has more than one film that
she's expressed regret over — and one of them was
a sequel to that John Carpenter original. We're
talking about "Halloween H20: 20 Years Later."
After sitting out four "Halloween"
sequels, she agreed to return in 1998,
but quickly realized she'd
made a mistake. Curtis told EW,
"To this day, I regret that I didn't say
to everyone, 'If Debra Hill's not the one
producing this movie, I'm not doing it. But what
ended up happening was, she wasn't part of it,
John wasn't part of it, and I was still part of
it, and it was a machine going down the road."
So far, we've covered a variety of reasons
actors regret even their biggest films.
But superstar Mark Wahlberg has a unique one,
and it involves his faith. A devout Catholic,
there are movies from his early days in Hollywood
that he looks back on with serious misgivings,
and chief among them is the 1997 comedy-drama
"Boogie Nights." It put the future A-lister
into the role of an adult film star, and while
it's always been met with stellar reviews and
has a fervent fan following, it's not
something that Wahlberg is proud of.
First came comments at a religious summit
in 2017 where the actor called out his
role as Diggler as something he
regrets. He told the audience,
"I just always hope that God is a movie fan
and also forgiving because I've made some
poor choices in my past. 'Boogie Nights'
is up there at the top of the list."
Quickly, those comments swept the web,
and Wahlberg had to explain further,
telling People Magazine that the role was one
that the Lord probably wasn't understanding of,
given its extremely adult connotations.
Wahlberg wasn't the only one to regret the film,
though. Co-star Burt Reynolds reportedly hated
the film so much that he fired his agent over it.
We can all sympathize with an
actor who regrets a bad movie,
but when it comes to Ahmed Best, things
get downright heartbreaking. A theater
performer whose career already included the
Broadway smash "Stomp," he was plucked from
the stage to play the first fully digital
main character in the "Star Wars" universe.
But because he played Jar Jar Binks,
Best became the target of fan outrage when the
first prequel film irked longtime diehards.
"Uh, you'za might be sayin' that."
The harassment Best received turned his
life upside down. Best said on Twitter,
"I faced a media backlash that
still affects my career today"
Most upsettingly, the actor admits that things
got so bad he seriously considered suicide.
Posting a photo of the New York harbor,
Best shared his story with his followers.
"This was the place I almost ended my
life. It's still hard to talk about."
Thankfully, Best was able to recover emotionally,
but not without years of turmoil.
He shared with Wired in 2017,
"There were a lot of tears,
there was a lot of pain."
It's fair to wonder if he wouldn't have been
better off without the role entirely. Still,
he made his return to the franchise in
a 2023 episode of "The Mandalorian."
"Star Trek" has a strong track record when it
comes to guest stars, going all the way back
to the original series, when Joan Collins
made an appearance in "City on the Edge of
Forever." The movies kept that tradition, with
Ricardo Montalban and Christopher Lloyd in the
second and third films. Cinematic takes on "Star
Trek: The Next Generation" followed suit. It was
"Clockwork Orange" star Malcolm McDowell who
filled the role of celebrity guest in 1994's
"Star Trek Generations," but from the sound of it,
he wasn't a happy camper when he made the movie.
According to McDowell, "Star Trek" was
stale and boring when he appeared in it,
and the cast was even worse.
Reported by TrekMovie, he said,
"I did them a favor [...] Patrick
Stewart spouting off for another
forty minutes. Jesus! If you find that
exciting, hey, go watch paint dry!"
The film, which was met with tepid
reviews, was a modest success,
but clearly isn't one that McDowell looks
back on with any amount of fondness.
Brad Pitt was just as huge
in the '90s as he is today,
starring in classics like "Seven" "Interview
with the Vampire" and "Fight Club."
"I want you to hit me as hard as you can."
He's not without his clunkers though, and the
worst of them all might be an entry from 1997
that the star himself seems to regret. Not just
because "The Devil's Own" was downright awful,
but because its production was
plagued with problems from start
to finish — problems that famously included
frequent clashes with co-star Harrison Ford.
All of those issues can probably be
traced to the fact that the project
got greenlit without any plan. Pitt told Newsweek,
"We had no script. Well, we had a great
script but it got tossed for various
reasons. To have to make something up as you
go along […] It was the most irresponsible
bit of filmmaking — if you can even
call it that — that I've ever seen."
He continued his rant,
"I couldn't believe it. I don't know why anyone
would want to continue making
that movie. We had nothing."
At one point, Pitt became so frustrated
that he asked to get out of the movie.
But the studio wasn't budging and
demanded a massive multi-million
dollar payout from their star if he
walked. In the end, the movie got made,
and while it paired two of Hollywood's
biggest names, it flopped in theaters.
Co-founder of the British comedy troupe Monty
Python, Michael Palin starred in one of the
freshest comedies of the '80s, "A Fish Called
Wanda." An uproariously funny film co-starring
Kevin Kline, Jamie Lee Curtis, and his Python
cohort John Cleese — who also co-wrote and
co-directed it — it won Kline an Academy Award
for best actor and remains beloved decades later.
Though they never made a sequel, the entire
cast reunited for a spiritual successor,
"Fierce Creatures," in 1997. But if
you ask Palin, it was a huge mistake.
Interviewed by The Telegraph decades
later, Palin lamented the entire process
of making the film. He described his
frustration at constant rewrites,
with Cleese even reducing his part
midway through filming. Palin remarked,
"That it took four months of my life [to film] is,
on the other hand, barely believable
from the amount of time on screen."
Even when filming first wrapped, the
experience wasn't over. Not long before
its planned release Palin was told that
early test screenings went poorly and
a wealth of reshoots were required.
With a newly recruited screenwriter,
Cleese overhauled the script yet again. Palin
seemed proud of the final product ... until
even more test screenings in New York forced
the whole thing to be cut down. Palin added,
"After all these years of time, energy,
money and hard graft, 'FC' looks likely
to be a 90-minute quickie, its shape and content
decided eventually by 20 people in Long Island."
No, Ewan McGregor doesn't regret "Star
Wars: Episode I — The Phantom Menace"
the way his co-star Ahmed Best does.
After all, he was able to parlay the
part into his own Obi Wan-centric series
on Disney+ some 20 years later. Instead,
the Scottish actor who came to fame thanks to
indie hit "Trainspotting" looks back with a
sense of disgust on the period drama "Emma,"
based on the classic novel by Jane Austen.
Asked which work in his career
he'd consider his worst,
McGregor was quick to answer. He said
in 2003 in a piece for The Guardian,
"Work wise? My character Frank Churchill
on 'Emma.' I made the decision to do that
film because I thought I should be seen to be
doing something different from 'Trainspotting."
He continued to lament is role,
"My decision-making was wrong [...] It's
a good film, 'Emma,' but I'm just ... not
very good in it. I'm not helped because
I'm also wearing the world's worst wig."
That said, while he may regret his performance
and the film, McGregor said he used it as a
valuable learning experience, and earned
a newfound understanding of how best to
pick his parts. Presumably, he now chooses
projects that offer him a better head of hair.
Austrian
bodybuilder-turned-actor-turned-politician
Arnold Schwarzenegger has a number of
films in his catalog he might wince at,
including his very first comedy, "Hercules in
New York." But that's not the one he regrets.
As a matter of fact, the one he seems
to have the most serious qualms about is
one that remains a cult favorite: The 1993
fantasy action-comedy, "Last Action Hero."
"Help me! Get me out of here!
My God. This man's not dead!"
A bomb in theaters, the film wasn't liked by
critics, and was seen by audiences as a huge
step down from his previous effort, "Terminator
2: Judgement Day." This reaction had the star
rethinking his entire career. He said
in his Netflix documentary, 'Arnold,'
"When 'Last Action Hero' came out, I had reached
my peak after 'Terminator 2', having the most
successful movie of the year worldwide. So,
when the reviews for the film rolled out,
I cannot tell you how upset that I was. It hurts
you. It hurts your feelings. It's embarrassing."
Glum over the negative response,
Arnold withdrew completely. He said:
"I didn't want to see anyone for a week."
To cope, he relied on support
from his family and friends,
including frequent collaborator James
Cameron. Cameron said in the series,
"He took it as a deep blow to his
brand. I think it really shook him."
Thanks to that support, Arnold
was able to overcome his regrets
and team back up with Cameron for his
comeback a year later in "True Lies."
British actor Hugh Grant has made plenty of
mistakes in his career. When it comes to his
movies, though, he definitely knows which one
he regrets most: "Nine Months." But it's not for
any of the usual reasons you'd expect. Despite it
being one of the worst movies in his filmography,
"Nine Months" isn't a movie he wishes he hadn't
done because it was bad, but because of who
financed it: controversial billionaire tycoon
Rupert Murdoch. He told Entertainment Weekly,
"It would certainly stick in my craw to
work for Fox. "I did make ["Nine Months"]
for them 16 years ago, but I was naïve then.
I didn't even know who owned [the studio]."
The comments came in response to a phone
hacking scandal that rocked Britain,
where the paper News of the World
was caught up in allegations that
it had tapped the phones of a number of
celebrities. Grant had helped catch them
in the act by recording a conversation with one
of their reporters, and went on record about
how disgusted he was by the paper's owner,
Murdoch, who also owned 20th Century Fox.
If you or anyone you know is having suicidal
thoughts, please call the National Suicide
Prevention Lifeline by dialing 988
or by calling 1-800-273-TALK (8255)​.